[Musica]
berlino
hai visto anche tu non mi guardare così
merlino dissero che ho visto qualcosa di
strano la fuori ormai sapete che tutti i
pazzi entrano a casa mia
sta rientrando qualcuno sta entrando
qualcuno o qualcosa ma scordiamoci sopra
letto poi parliamo
ok sono salita sopra letto a céline i
pupazzi e ma gurlino tu non puoi salire
altrimenti mangeresti tutti i più bassi
qualsiasi cosa forse sembra che se ne
sia andata forse mi sono immaginato
tutto possiamo anche scendere che allora
merely nato arrivando
[Musica]
che cos'è bambino non puoi nasconderti
qui altrimenti si accorgerà
mi sembra peggio di aiuto di oggi
marino non guardare qua se non si
accorge che sono guai
sta cercando
sarà assurda come granny potevo sentire
il mio odore si suicida
[Musica]
la porta
si è creduto lecce
chi è successo sono ancora qui nel letto
insieme ai miei pupazzi però c'era
scritto 0 2
quindi vuol dire che piguet come granny
abbiamo cinque giorni per riuscire a
vincere questa challenge altrimenti non
so cosa succederà se perdo questa
challenge ma speriamo che non succeda
ovviamente voi fate il tifo per me
lasciate un bel mi piace su questo video
se questo video raggiunge il 40 mila mi
piace giocheremo anche a pighi 2 nella
realtà dobbiamo elaborare assieme una
strategia per confondere i picchi perché
mi sembra che sia mi sembra che sia un
pochino più intelligente di g non che ci
voglia molto ad essere intelligenti dei
gremi non mi seguite ancora su instagram
andati a seguirmi il nome en eaters
doris
se volete seguitemi anche su tik tok ho
fatto un regalo inaspettato a vitale
se volete vedere cosa gli ho regalato
alla sua reazione andate a seguirmi su
tik tok e ora siete pronti scendiamo giù
da questo letto e cerchiamo di
sconfiggere tutti in ogni modo di no
andiamo
proviamo ad uscire da qua e proprio lì
pg
ma allora non posso uscire di qua
no subito di uscito controllando
l'uscita dalla camera dobbiamo trovare
un piano alternativo per uscire da
questa camera chiamo provare a distrarla
in qualche modo
vediamo se abbiamo avuto un'idea
guardate io qua o un maialino
salvadanaio magari pitti siccome un
maialino verrà distratta dai minimi
non so come ma proviamo ecco il maialino
salvadanaio no berlino non è per te non
è per te e per pd ok dopo sciacqua sul
tavolo
vediamo come reagirà picchi contiamoci
prima mi piacerebbe magari speriamo
sembra che le piaccia
harry potter molto
[Musica]
stop alla camera guardiamo al piano di
sotto
non so se più che riuscì a scendere le
scale questo è il nascondiglio perfetto
la casetta andiamo chiudiamo la porta
penso che qua pino mi troverò mai vuoi
venire anche tu nella mia casetta pieni
di però devi fare silenzio che c'è così
quando potremo usarlo contro picking è
viva bravissimo berlino sei sempre
l'aiutante più bravo di tutti che però
non posso darti lomellino mi dispiace è
che ora dobbiamo nasconderci ok
il nostro obiettivo e scappare da questa
casa senza essere presi cinque volte da
pt quindi cerca di aiutarmi berlino bene
ora che abbiamo questo penso che sarà
molto più facile difendersi da picchi
vero un berlino quindi aspettiamo solo
che si avvicini e per ecco la lasciò la
vedete
prepariamo questo perché non funziona
non fare niente
ho perso un altro gioco forse questo era
una trappola perché non funziona
eppure ai gommini dentro come funziona
se non fate niente
o forse devo ricaricare da qua sopra
non avevo ricaricato bene vediamo ora se
funziona avete sentito ha funzionato
berlino spostati devo un bel carpentiere
devo fare la guardia aspettare che
arrivi eccola
spero di riuscire a prenderla si è
fermato si tratta peraltro deve scappare
da qua
[Musica]
beccati questo piano
ok ho capito praticamente se glielo
colpisco con uno di questi rimane fermo
per qualche secondo
quindi devo approfittarne è riuscire a
scappare mentre io la capisco una cosa
che devo provare provare a colpirla più
volte così magari o no perso un altro
giorno quanti giorni mi rimangono due a
uno ho perso il conto siamo vicini alla
porta d'uscita
il problema è che ho solamente uno due
tre quattro colpi spero che basteranno
per riuscire a uscire vincere la silence
propria madre
per ora via libera qua ho paura che
picchi sconti all'improvviso ecco la
porta è chiusa
devo trovare la chiave e ho fatto un
sacco di rumore che mi posso prc questi
pazienti non ha gente qua dentro
l'edizione è costato ferma lì
[Musica]
qua dentro mercati quel pizzico di 4
secondi abbiamo fatto ragazzi abbiamo
vinto la challenge contro pinky perché
siamo riusciti a uscire fuori dalla casa
mi raccomando lasciati un bel mi piace
se volete vedere una seconda parte con
pighi
io mi sposto questo nel frattempo perché
sta piovendo volete vedere gesti quando
parti che un pg l'estate un bel mi piace
40 mila mi piace ci sarà la seconda
parte e ora vi lascio qua 4 caselline
esplicare provvedere i nostri altri
video cliccate su quelle che preferite e
buio rifiuti